اذا اسبوع مره على اعتداء اسطنبول الذي
راح ضحيته سته قتلى وعشرات الجرحى اتهمت
انقره وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه بالوقوف
خلفه وتوعدت بالرد فكان الرد بعمليه اطلقت
عليها انقره اسم المخلب السيف بدات ليلى
السبت الاحد دمرت خلالها الطائرات الحربيه
89 هدفا وافقه ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه العمليه طالت مناطق واسعه في شمال
العراق وشمال سوريا قنديل
وهاكورك شمال العراق وعين العرب وتل رفعت
والمالكيه شمال سوريا الدفاع التركيه قالت
ان القواعد المستهدفه شملت ملاجئ وكفوفا
وانفاقا ومستودعات ذخيره ومقرات ومعسكرات
تدريب تابعه لحزب العمال الكردستاني في
العراق ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في
سوريا
في هذا السياقه العمليه التي نفذت ضد
اهداف ارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا
منذ منتصف ليل هذا المساء تم التخطيط لها
بحساسيه ولحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح
لكن ماذا عن القتله المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان افاد بوقوع 65 قتيلا وجريحا في
محافظات حلب والحسكه والرقه المرصد اشار
الى ان بين القتل 13 من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه قصد اضافه الى الناشط اعلامي
في منطقه جبل في المالكيه وريف الدرباسيه
وريف ابو راسين بينما قتل 12 عنصرا من
قوات النظام السوري الى جانب عنصر من
القوات الكرديه في شمال غرب حلب وشمال غرب
الحسكه وشمال الرقه بالتزامن اصدر جهاز
مكافحه الارهاب في كردستان العراق بيانا
قال فيه ان تركيا نفذت اكثر من 25 عمليه
قصف جوي استهدفت مقرات ومواقع لحمايه
لوحدات حمايه الشعب وحزب العمال
الكردستاني وتم التاكيد على ان
و30 من مسلحين وحدات حمايه الشعب وحزب
العمال الكردستاني قتلوا وجرح عدد اخر منه
او غيرهم اضافه اليهم القصف طالما مناطق
الحسكه وريف حلب والرقه وعين العرب شمال
سوريا وكره قضاء ماوت وصفح قنديل وجبال
كورك واسيس ومنطقه برادوست شمالا العراق
[موسيقى]
اصرفت تركيا على اتهام حزب العمال ووحدات
حمايه الشعب الكرديه بالوقوف خلف تفجير
اسطنبول رغم فيهما اي علاقه لهما بالتفجير
رغم ذلك سنه انقره العمليه
لتنهي ضرباتها التي تسببت بمذبح بحق
المدنيين والصحافيين في المالكيه وفق وصف
المتحدث باسم قسد فرهاد شامي بينما رات
الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا ان
تفجير اسطنبول ما هو الا ذريعه لتبرير
هجوم تركيا على شمال وشرق سوريا الاداره
الذاتيه الكرديه ناشدت المجتمع الدولي
والدول الضامنه للقيام بمسؤولياتها لوقف
ما اسمته العدوان اضافه الى الممارسات لا
انسانيه كافه لتركيا كما جاء في البيت